- Strongly agree.
- Strongly disagree.
- Somewhat agree.
- Somewhat disagree.
- I would agree.
- Disagree
- Disagree.
- Hello, my name's Shi'anna Whitman
and I am the editor of this episode
of Spectrum Jubilee Employees.
This has become a tradition
here at Jubilee over the years.
We have certainly grown as a
company over the last year.
And with that,
so have our ideas and opinions.
In this episode,
you'll be able to hear
what Jubilee employees really
think about things like this.
- I feel like in every
single person at Jubilee,
I would kiss them for a different reason.
- And this.
- [Director] Jubilee will
still be around in 50 years.
- Uh-oh.
- Wow.
- And also this is your friendly reminder
to be kind in the comments because...
- Sometimes the comments can
be pretty brutal and mean.
- [Shi'anna] So buckle up,
because you're in for a real treat.
- [Director] I have had a
crush on someone in the office.
Three, two, one.
- Define crush.
- [Director] You define crush.
- Wow. Strongly disagree.
Really?
- My girlfriend's watching this.
I can't...
I'm taken, ladies.
I can't like,
be messing with this.
So, strongly disagree.
- I feel like there's a
lot of people who like,
when they started Jubilee you're like,
"Oh. They have a very
attractive personality
and they're very attractive."
But like, it's gotten to
the point where I'm like,
Oh. If me and this person
were to date or something.
I think friend crushes
happen a lot at Jubilee.
I had friend crush on Zach when he joined.
- Aww.
Can you guys do this in private, maybe?
- I'm definitely on somewhat
disagree because of like,
friend crushes, you know?
- Well, I didn't know that counted.
- I Think you guys have been so diplomatic
by saying, "friend crush."
- Yeah.
- Come on. We don't wanna
know about friend crush.
We wanna know about actual crush.
- Feelings of desire
can kind of be ambiguous
of whether or not it's actually...
If it's platonic or if it's like,
something more than that.
- I think...
I'm a 23 year old like,
single woman in LA.
I'm just checking out
everyone all the time.
I love to check people out and you know,
the qualities of the people
that work at Jubilee like,
a lot of emotionally intelligent people.
A lot of sensitive, soft people.
These are like my
favorite types of people.
So like, I feel like in every
single person at Jubilee,
I would kiss them for a different reason.
You know?
Like, they all have qualities that...
You don't like that, Steven?
You don't like the way I said that?
- I mean...
I wouldn't kiss everyone.
- It doesn't have to be with Tina.
You're the one who said I
don't have a crush on Stephen.
- [Director] I love reading the comments.
Three, two, one.
- No, I don't bother with
the comments section.
I mean, sometimes they're funny.
But sometimes people are just mean
and it makes me lose faith
in humanity a little bit
to see so much like,
very specific cruelty.
- I kind of agree with that.
That sometimes the comments
can be pretty brutal and mean.
But I think as a director,
sometimes I get pretty
good feedback from comments
because people have good
suggestions about different topics
on how the video could have been better
with maybe a few different
prompts or different cast.
So it's not that I take
everything seriously,
but it's like one of my
guilty pleasures also.
- I think it's also just
a really good way to see
if the content that we're
even making even resonates
with our audience.
- But, yeah.
Like, if we didn't like,
look at the comments,
we'd probably just like,
evaluate our videos by the views.
Which there are so many videos that like,
don't get a lot of views but are like,
some of the videos that
we're most proud of.
- Yeah. I'm on the same wavelength.
I think we create content
for our audiences so like,
it's always good to know what
we think we're doing right
and what we may be doing wrong.
And because I have been in
like a few little videos.
Brandon showed me this one website
where you could search up like,
specific topics.
So I always look for my name.
Because I wanna know what
people think about me!
I wanna be liked.
- Going off of Milky's point.
I can definitely attest to like,
checking the comments to make
sure we're doing a good job
As an editor,
I put a lot of jokes in
that sometimes I'm worried will
go over the audience's head
or like,
they just won't get it.
My humor is different from
that of the audience's.
So it's a process of like,
learning what the audience
likes in terms of jokes.
Also making sure we, you know,
are hitting our targets in terms of like,
what the video is about.
Are we engaging our
community in the right way?
There are also instances of like,
people doxxing people in the comments
that I think we do have a
responsibility to look out for.
- And our channel is left leaning.
So, a lot of people who have opinions
that are right leaning,
they definitely are under attack.
For so many videos.
- I think we have to be
really cognizant of like,
tunnel vision and just like,
the echo chamber of the same
voices saying the same thing.
- Yeah.
- [Director] No topic or
identity should be off limits
on our platform.
Three, two, one.
- Part of what like,
why I fell in love with Jubilee
and why I like working here is
because we do take the
time to show both sides.
Even if it is stuff or from people
that I normally wouldn't agree with.
Because if I don't know
how the other side thinks
and I don't know like,
what is causing them pain.
Like, I don't know how to win them over.
And if I don't know how to win them over,
Then...
Like, I can't hope for a better world.
Like, changing minds is important.
- I do think like,
our whole mission is to
help create understanding
on different points of views.
But there are definitely
some points of views
that I feel like are overly negative.
Things that could be related to...
Hate crime provoking conversation.
- But that also depends on
how we showcase that content,
right?
Like, how we represent them.
I think we should cover all topics
and there's nothing off limits.
Because at the end of the day,
I do think like,
nobody's born good or bad.
It's the choices that
defines who they are.
I think only if we try to explore topics
that make us uncomfortable,
can we create less divide amongst people?
Of course that would be a lot
of responsibility for us
as a company to make sure
that the opinions of the
people are their opinions,
and Jubilee doesn't
endorse anything like that.
I think it's fine.
- I think just that a lot of
misinformation can be spread.
And I know that we are
very popular on like,
platforms like Facebook.
And a lot of older people may
get their news from Facebook
and they may like,
cherry pick this clip,
this moment.
And like,
that could be incredibly influential
to a huge amount of people.
- I think it's important to remember also
that platforming is not endorsing.
You know.
Just because we put
something on out platform,
doesn't mean we agree with it.
That's why we have something
like a verbal disclaimer
on middle ground now.
Yeah. Come on over.
- But I think overall,
this is maybe just a larger
conversation about censorship
and like,
what we believe should
be said and not said.
And I think that's what a lot
of private companies are kind
of considering now too.
Which is why like,
you know,
Twitter banned Trump
and same with Facebook.
I wonder if these big
corporations are doing
that to protect the
overall good of people.
I feel like we should in a way follow suit
and be really considerate
of the people that would...
Our audiences that would
be watching our videos.
- I feel like I could honestly be
on that side with you both.
But I'm coming at it more from
like the business perspective
of the fact that like,
our content lives on YouTube.
And we are kind of like,
at the mercy of content
guidelines of YouTube.
So like,
if there's some sort
of topic or perspective
that is gonna get us like,
flagged.
Get demonetized.
That's messing with the livelihoods
of all the people that
work for this company.
That's where I'm moreso coming from
If it's moreso in terms of a
business longevity perspective.
- [Director] I need a raise.
Three, two one.
- Oh, man.
I thought everyone was gonna go like,
strongly agree.
- We seem greedy.
- I was thinking about going to disagree.
But I mean,
we all need a raise, right?
- Yeah.
- Can we all agree that like...
- Yeah. Need is greater than want.
Like want, I think a
lot of us would be here.
But need is...
- Okay.
If we're going like desperately need,
then I'm gonna go over here.
- Well, I don't think it
should be desperately need.
- Yeah. It depends on how you see it.
I think that's how I perceive it.
- Do you deserve a raise?
I think is like,
kind of...
- I don't need a raise.
- I think you should demand
more out of yourself.
You work a lot of hours.
On the weekends sometimes.
Late into the night sometimes.
- I think media companies generally pay
their employees less.
So if I compare to other media companies
from whatever I've heard,
I think we have a pretty decent salary.
But yeah.
If you compare to the
amount of work we put in.
The hours we put in.
Sometimes working weekends.
And also a lot of times
the emotional labor
that goes in the work
which is a lot of it.
Especially for specific shows
or specific time of the year.
And then I just think a
gradual raise would be good.
I'm somebody who just
can't ask for a raise.
And I think that's my flaw.
That I should be more straightforward
and should demand what I deserve.
Because the companies run by people.
And of course they'll try
to save money if they can.
Right?
- That's right.
And it's actually true
that this year at any job,
if you didn't get a raise,
you got a pay cut because of inflation.
So, even more reason.
- I also think we're all in our twenties,
and we are all single.
Like, none of us are married right?
So that's why we are more
in this range in the middle.
I think if any of us had
responsibility of a child
or had our own family
we would be on the other side.
- Yeah.
- On the extreme side.
- [Director] Our company
exists in a political bubble.
Three, two, one.
- This is so hard.
- Oh, man.
- As we mentioned like,
we are all like,
more left-leaning.
But in the very first
spectrum Jubilee episode,
we talked about how I feel
like important it was for like,
us to hire a Trump supporter.
- In terms of like thoughts
and opinions on things,
I think we can be more diverse.
- And we need a Trump voter,
like you guys were saying.
- And maybe we've done that since,
maybe we haven't.
But if we have,
I don't think we've created an environment
where that person feels comfortable enough
to be vocal in our team about like,
"Yes. I have supported Trump."
Or, "Yes. I am more conservative."
- Do you guys know single
conservative on our team?
- I do know like,
a current employee who's conservative only
because of one of the shows
that I was involved in made
so the staff had to talk to
us about this stuff privately.
And they, you know,
kind of made a joke about it
and said something off the cuff like,
"Oh. Well, you know,
I'm kind of the black like,
the secret black sheep."
- I think we try our best to like,
burst the bubble.
And sometimes we do,
but then we always catch
ourselves getting back
into the bubble because
we are very left leaning.
- I think it's really naive to even like,
consider that we might actually like,
not exist within the
political bubble at all.
- Yeah.
- Because like,
even at the core of like,
who we are as people like,
all of our unconscious biases
are gonna affect the way
that we work.
And they're always gonna
affect the way that we interact
with people and the ideas
that we come up with.
- That's why I'm over here is
because I know we're not exempt.
You know?
We see it in the content we make.
- But a lot of our content is political.
So I think that at that
point we get people
who have different views.
But inevitably,
things would happen since
we're so left leaning
that even if we accept someone,
their beliefs might come in
the way of how we function.
So maybe they wouldn't
work for the company.
For example,
I think most of us are
very anti-gun, right?
But if we hire someone,
maybe who's pro-gun
and brings a gun to the office
because they need it for their safety,
I think a lot of us will
have a problem with that.
With someone bringing a gun.
- Yeah.
- So just by the nature of our work
and the side we lean towards,
I think we are in our bubble.
- [Director] Jubilee will
still be around in 50 years.
Three, two, one.
- Oh dear. So we'll be like, 75-70.
70's.
Oh, no.
- Oh, no!
- Uh-oh.
- Wow.
I mean, I hope Jubilee is
still around in like 50 years.
And I know like,
Jason, our CEO, loves to talk about
how Jubilee is a huge
movement for empathy.
And he has like huge, huge ambitions.
And us on YouTube is just like,
the very, very start of this movement.
I don't know.
I guess sometimes it's just discouraging.
Like, if you compare Jubilee
right now in terms of like,
views and engagement with our audience.
We have grown in subscribers.
But at the same time,
I feel like our engagement
has gone down a good amount.
- The idea of Jubilee has only existed
for a little more than 10 years by now.
It's very hard to guess where we'll be,
if we'll be in 50 years.
I guess I'm just a little more optimistic.
- Who's to say that like,
where we are at is like,
the best that we will ever be?
- I mean, Disney 50 years
in was already making like,
whatever, Snow White.
Or whatever Disney movie came out 50 years
after they started so...
- Accepted is no less than Snow White.
- Everyone watch Accepted.
Streaming on Amazon Prime and...
- Apple TV.
- That's right, Apple TV.
- [Milky] 100% on rotten tomatoes.
- [Brandon] 100%.
Great documentary.
- Specifically,
I actually asked Jason
that exact question.
If he thought Jubilee was
gonna be around for 50 years.
He told me that he wanted
to be the Disney of empathy.
And I was kind of like,
(scoffs) look at this guy.
He's gonna be Disney?
But then I asked him like,
how are you able to be so
ambitious and think that big?
And he told me that one of
his friends who was just like,
I think a coder in college,
ended up creating Dropbox.
Like, that's his personal friend.
And because he saw his
friend able to do that,
he just thought,
"Well, if my friend can do that,
why can't I do that?"
And it gave me such a
valuable lesson about like,
the types of people that you choose
to surround yourself with.
That once they rise up,
you rise up too.
So, that's why I'm very
thankful to be surrounded
by such talented people, too.
That I know will all be successful.
So, like...
If you guys are gonna do it,
I'm gonna do it too.
- (beep) Yeah.
- We'll all be here.
- Yeah.
- Empty here.
- At Jubilee?
- And we survived the pandemic also.
Which was...
Which would've really jolted the company,
which it did in a way.
But we still passed through that phase.
And I think the mission of
Jubilee and what it stands
for is just the ethos of the
company is here to stay on
for pretty long.
- Snaps to that. Right?
- Wait, everyone.
You gotta do it slightly
after the first person.
- Three, two, one.
Beautiful.
- Now we're coming back up.
And then the other side.
Okay.
- Does it look cool?
- This is why we put nobody in front.
- Does this look great?
- I'm proud to be a citizen of my country.
♪ I'm proud to be an American. ♪